cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus joins us for more
on what's next in the nation's
nine-month-long battle against the
coronavirus doctor good morning great to
see you
two vaccines have hit the efficacy and
safety mark so far but the astrazeneca
oxford vaccine still has some question
marks
should we have ultimately at least three
vaccines available
hey great to see you at the table um the
answer to me clearly is yes the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
had a a trial done and they
there were two different doses in the
trial long story how they got there
but both of them worked and when both of
them worked
it's clear to me that we need something
out there more doses and so
if there's a third vaccine that's tens
of millions of more people who can be
vaccinated in the short run
when there were no safety issues at all
so my hope is
that all three vaccines get out there by
the way the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
nonprofit
and the largest manufactured vaccine in
the world
and also that not needing that sub-zero
refrigeration rate
as well which a lot of people are
excited about david the here and now we
don't have a vaccine right now
cases are up hospitalizations are up
everything continues to rise is there
any reason to think
that that will change as we get closer
to another holiday or is that the trend
that will continue
every single holiday we've had there's
been a significant increase 50
or more you know 10 to 14 days after the
holiday and the same thing will happen
here unfortunately
50 people an hour are dying in the
united states right now at coven 19
and those numbers are only going to go
up and so i am
worried about the next six to eight
weeks i really am
dr a uh reports indicate that the cdc is
thinking about
changing its quarantine rules from a
period
of two weeks to seven to ten days what
would your advice be
so the reason for that is a lot of
people are not complying with the 14
days i can't miss 14 days of work i'm
going to get fired economically i can't
handle it
how can my child not interact with
anybody for 14 days
so limiting it to 7 to 10 days with a
test we'll probably
cut down slightly the number of people
diagnosed but at the same time hopefully
it'll dramatically increase compliance
and i'm all for it seven to ten days
with a test makes sense
if you were at your holiday parties and
there was that cousin or that uncle who
you know
is going out all the time and you had
interactions with him
or her then you need to quarantine for
seven to 10 days and get a test or your
children do when they come home
we all have to pay our part to stop the
spread of this virus
we sure do hey doc the fda recently
approved
an at-home testing kit is that
potentially
the future of testing when it comes to
the coronavirus this at-home idea
you know and we've been talking about
this for a long time at home testing and
this is
a test where you can actually do a
molecular test at home so good
sensitivity and very good test the
problem is
they can't really make them and so it's
going to be months before it's out there
and it's not going to make a significant
dent on the market
unfortunately we have a major issue
still with testing in this country we
just don't have enough of them in the
right places
getting them at home would be fantastic
but
it's not on the near timeline
unfortunately and so while i like the
idea
we shouldn't change what we're doing now
because of that test yeah a lot of
people looking forward to seeing that
happen but
again it's a ways off as you mentioned
dr david agus
we thank you always for joining us